[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me get to jim jackson nba on tnt
jim do you have all your trading cards
when you were playing did you collect
your cards
well you know it's a lot of cars to
collect with different teams how many i
played for
how much do you get paid by the card
companies
uh i mean it's i'm not telling you how
much i get paid it's well you know what
it's it's an amount i'm with panini and
we'll do stuff because they're you know
sponsored with
not sponsored their sponsor of the nba
so uh my rookie card my second year card
some other cars i'll do something on a
yearly basis and we'll sign a bunch of
cards and okay some individual
signatures but it's a good gig though
all right my mother has my mother has a
lot more than i do
of you
yeah just you
yeah oh yeah
any of them worth a lot of money
no
all right at least you're honest
yeah all right so help me understand the
boston celtics
do they have a style offensively
because i i'm trying to figure it out
like what is what is their offense
it works sometimes and sometimes it
doesn't
well and that's because
you know when you look at this boston
team and kind of
the things that they fought over in the
past of trying to establish
uh especially tatum and brown as young
players in this league when you're young
you want to establish that bravado that
you can play that you belong that you
deserve the contract that you deserve
the accolades and sometimes that
conflicts with the overall offensive
scheme i think brad stevens had an issue
with that email udoka had an issue with
that at the beginning
but it kind of started to evolve into
this team atmosphere when the ball moved
you remember when boston was playing
uh
before kyrie when the ball was hopping
around and
boston celtics look this was maybe uh uh
jalen and
to jason's rookie year they got the
easter camera final and even some of the
second year the ball is just moving
that's the style i think emay wants to
play a lot coming from san antonio where
the ball doesn't stick
the problem is
trying to change that within a year
structure i can't have everybody on the
same plate when you see boston play like
they did last night you're like well why
can't they do it all the time well it's
a level of offensive maturity that they
have to get to and if you find success
in it hopefully it extends that and
that's the mantra that you play with all
the time instead of fighting it so that
it's a very legitimate question
when you ask that there was a moment
i've mentioned this a couple of times uh
in previous hours where jaylen brown has
draymond green on him
and and there's going to be a pick set
where there's going to be a switch where
jaylen brown is going to be guarded by
steph curry which would be a big big
advantage you would think for jalen
he waves off the pick
he doesn't need the pick he beats
draymond
off the dribble and then another time on
the wing a couple plays down a couple
plays later beat him off the dribble
left-handed
i
i'm not sure who draymond thinks he is
now
but the boston celtics aren't that
concerned about him as far as the player
maybe the agitator but not the player
you agree well but yeah i agree with
this draymond is best shoot defensively
off the ball when he's helping him
taking charges deep into rebounds uh
there was a point in time when he was a
very good on-ball defender meaning that
he could stay in front
but right now being a little bit older
in age of wear and tear guys are able to
break draymond down a little bit more
now here's the difference too i think a
lot of times when the ball moves side to
side
and then you attack the golden state's
defense or any defense has not said
that's when you have better angles you
have better chances to get in but then
you also time and score when you go but
jaylen brown jason taylor they did a
bridge i thought great job last night of
exploiting when they went quick
against whether it was draymond green
whether it was steph whether it was otto
porter even at times against clay where
they identified where the opportunity
was and they took advantage of
all right if you're golden state what do
you do
well it's not a lot of it just you gotta
stop turning the ball over honestly i
mean
we always try to go and say with this we
say this is a team that you know highly
intelligent they're experienced team
they know how to play but yet and still
you scratch your head at times then it's
like why would you turn the ball over i
mean you had momentum coming off the
third quarter but immediately at the
beginning of the fourth quarter it's
like four quick turnover and these
things are on these things are avoidable
you're going to turn the ball over don't
get me wrong but these live ball
turnovers and some of the mental
mistakes you see when stepped through it
tried to throw it half court full court
together and that was coming off of
another turnover right before yeah so
you took all that momentum away that you
got in the third quarter and turned it
over so to me you value the basketball
and secondly
what they did to win game two in a lot
of their games they controlled the pain
listen they got boston at 52 points in
the paint
okay
and go and see that 26.
different between the game right there
boston was a more physical team they got
inside the paint whether there was layup
second shots
fast break opportunities those are the
things you got to clean up if you go to
state but that's why i didn't understand
this that the celtics are a far bigger
team
and your two best players can get to the
hoop off the dribble
and
i would be taking advantage of that i i
would just i know they love to shoot the
threes of course but man i gotta i i
want to beat you inside get you in foul
trouble i i want to make you pay every
single time down the floor
but isn't that too easy
but that's a simple way right that that
would be a little bit too easy but when
you look at the number it tells you
okay you got 52 points in the paint
how did you get it again a combination
of fast break points
off the draw off the dribble
second shots it's not like you're
getting 52 points and you're posting up
that that's not how yeah yeah williams
offensive rebound the key to success to
me and this is what made golden state so
tough to stop during the championship
run and even this year
yes they beat you with the three but
they got a lot of layups they got a lot
of second shot
and
yes the three is a potent weapon but
when you come down to winning the
championship you really watch it those
two point conversion when you just keep
getting them keep getting them and your
opponent doesn't and they're missing
guess what you start to extend that
league
yeah and that's what boston was able to
do i mean but again it's so simple
sometimes bro look two plus two still
equal four to me
it really does jim there was a moment
last night where the everybody was on
the perimeter it's almost like if they
could have been out of bounds they would
have been out of bounds and i wondered
where would shaquille o'neal be
if i just dropped a perimeter if if i
shaq would be on the perimeter yeah you
know why i had this uh conversation with
alonso morning he said well if i played
in today's game
i would be doing this and i said no you
wouldn't he said well why wouldn't i i
said because
from the time that you were 12 13 years
old you wouldn't be playing in the polls
so you wouldn't be a you wouldn't be the
same alonso morning you wouldn't be the
same shaquille o'neal shaquille would be
i think more of a hybrid like joel
embiid because of his skill set
now i don't know if he will be able to
shoot the same way but he would grow up
shooting the basketball picking and
popping he wouldn't grow up
on the post and the same can be said
vice versa dan you know you have this
conversation all the time people say
well steph couldn't play back in the day
i'm like well why couldn't he muggy bose
did
d brown did mark price did
uh uh michael adams did isaiah spud webb
did isaiah and you know why
they drew up in the era were playing in
the playground and playing physical
playing outside at the park was in the
alley was a part of their dna so steph
if you take him back
he would have been taught to play that
way you can't take step game right now
and say plug it back into 1985 or 1990
because him growing up he would have
been taught to play the game
a lot different
he's uh nba on tnt analyst the clippers
analyst as well jim jackson joining us
on the program yeah this whole debate
where cedric maxwell was saying to
draymond green you know back in our day
they'd rough you up a little bit and
then draymond saying oh everybody seems
like they were enforcer back then
well
the thing i would say to draymond green
is
the nba would never let you rough up
luka doncic the way the pistons roughed
up michael jordan they would never let
you rough up the nice players the
popular players the best player in the
game
under the nba rules at the time
they had the jordan rules that they had
the best player and they were beating
him up that's the difference i think
that draymond has to understand not
everybody was rick mchorn not everybody
you know was this tough guy
but
these teams made you pay
if if you were on a roll you go to the
hoop
you may get knocked down but it was just
called basketball back then
it was but you know each era always has
its iteration what's your favorite era
of music dan
70s 60s 60s right so mine is like
80s 90s hip-hop r b and the reason why
is because it's nostalgic to me because
that's what i grew up a lot of my growth
period was during that time when i was
younger watching stuff and listening to
music and when i hear it now it brings
me back to those nostalgic times good or
bad and it's the same thing with sports
when we grow up so we don't want to let
the past go in regards to what we felt
helped mature us at a time in our life
so we want to stick with it and say this
time was better this listen i'm a
historian bro i love to travel i love to
see old buildings some old buildings are
awesome some old buildings or not some
of the newer buildings right now are
just fabulous but
history
and games they can't stay the same david
stern understood that the nba understood
this game was going to be international
look at mlb look at hockey look at nfl
what you want more scoring you want more
excitement all the these professional
sports have changed in order to bring a
lot more excitement freedom of movement
that's in hockey whether that's in
football you want to be able to throw
the ball downfield because you want more
scoring
that's just how it is i'm not one of
those guys older guys well you know back
in the 90s and this is this and these
guys can't play no
you know the game has to change in order
for it to survive and get better and get
new fans and that's what the nba has
done
which team would be the best team in the
nba if i took away the three-point shot
phoenix like they were because they
shoot a lot of mid-range shots between
chris paul and devin booker
um you have deandre ayton inside who can
score the ball when you give it to him
so he and he can shoot the basketball
from inside
um
you know if you took away the three they
didn't rely on it a lot now they would
knock down shots yeah i think their
biggest thing was that they just didn't
have a third guy that could beat him off
the dribble but i loved the way phoenix
played
uh darvin hamm seemed to say all the
right things about russell westbrook he
had to say all the right things about
russell westbrook
what do you think deep down he feels
about russell westbrook and how to make
this work
i don't know that's a good question i
mean because darwin has been around i
think he has a lot of respect i think
coaches come in
just like organizations say you know
what if we get him here
i believe that with our philosophy that
we can
not change him
but help him see a different avenue to
success but the biggest question is this
dan
who does russell westbrook ultimately
want to be next year
that's that's what it comes down to
forget organization and the coach
carmelo anthony had to make that same
transition i'm not saying russell was
there
but carmelo had to look at himself in
the mirror and say okay i'm carmelo of
today not 15 years ago 10 years but it
took him a while to come to that
realization well of course but some of
the greatest players it takes a while to
get there because you're so accustomed
to being the number one alpha the guy
that scores the basketball and being
able to do whatever you want on the
court but as you age
you're going to lose something so the
question is when you look in the mirror
who do you see
the pass player
or the one that's currently playing
because if you're stuck in the past
those habits and that mindset is not
going to be changed but if you flip the
strip and say you know i can still be
valuable
at this age but i have to understand
what my role is that's the same thing
with russell westbrook his biggest asset
is his confidence
his biggest downfall is his confidence
that time so
darby hans can say what he won genie
busted say what they want
it's all up to russell westbrook and the
mentality of what he wants to bring to
the table for the lakers this year but i
think you came off the bench you're
around 32. does that sound about right
yeah yeah a little bit a little bit
before too because when i went to
portland
um my in 98 99 i came off the [ __ ]
which was tough
okay
but
it worked
and so up and down i sacramento came off
the bus houston i started miami i
started phoenix i came off the bench
it's tough to keep track of all the
teams you played for
who you telling
i tell you what though at every
in every stop
the bank's still working
all right okay
that was still a pretty good indication
[Laughter]
and you played 13 games for the lakers
so you know no no not really i sat down
for about 11 years
what was the best part of playing for
the lakers even for those 13 games
oh getting to know kobe a lot more
really because i knew kobe had 18 when
he came in and competed against him and
played against them
but when you're around a person on a
daily basis sort of speaking not to say
that kobe and i were best friends but we
had a chance to
hang out and go to dinner and talk just
about life and game and philosophy and
in that short period of time
i kind of knew the mindset behind
the player and he averaged 35 a game
that year oh my yeah oh my god i mean
just how he prepared himself with the
injuries and his body
to get ready now
and again then i had an opportunity to
play with some hall of fame players
whether it's tracy mcgrady jason kidd
yao ming
um
you know chris webber
um the list goes on on alonzo morning
guys i've played with
but kobe was different man
this dude was just i mean allen iverson
played with ai but this is his second
year
hope he was just different animal man
wasn't wasn't perfect didn't always say
or do things the right way which is okay
but it was that competitive nature man
no matter who he played against who it
was
if it was a big-name player he wanted to
prove
okay i'm colby
you got to work up to my level i got
there was a game where you and kobe
combined for 57.
yeah what i have two yeah
it's all about sacrificing that's what
it seems i like it man i like it i i
grew into that
maybe russell westbrook needs to talk to
you
well but he still i think russell still
has a lot in the tank
but he has to understand
who he is as a player and what he can
bring to that team
what he did in okc or what he did in
houston or what he did in washington is
not the same and i will say this in
defense of russell
him going through that bad streak last
year with la was tough to get out of why
his usage race wasn't the same if he was
in washington and went through a
four or five game bad shooting streak he
could get his way out of it because the
ball will be in his hands and he can do
more things with the lakers the
opportunities to get out of that are not
the same so you got to change your
mindset
it's always great to talk to you
thank you bud
hey you know what i want to ask a
question
did you collect all of that stuff over
all the years somebody give them to okay
so what made you
is that just
are you a hoarder or is that just
something
i was a hoarder before it was called a
hoarder i just collected i never threw
away anything
well i could tell
like i just
i kept everything and uh i just brought
it here in the man cave so
but you know what it's kind of cool now
when you think about it like people
hoard stuff like you need to get rid of
it but when you have a platform like
this and you can kind of put it all
together
now it brings back i mean it's kind of
cool to see i just wanted to know i
didn't know yeah
i got an autographed kobe jersey
what number eight or 24. i got 24
all-star jerseys says to the white mamba
nice so you know that you know i'm
hanging in the rafters
that's that crypto number 24. yeah
yeah yeah yeah me and colby shared live
in college yeah because that that was
your jersey before it became kobe's
other girls yeah yeah i love them nice
team player team player right there
that's maturity thank you jim
that's jim jackson one of our favorites
nba on tnt we'll take a break last call
for phone calls what we learn what's in
store tomorrow back after this